good morning
yesterday i interviewed the candidates
put forward by
the irish government for the post of
commissioner
mrs murray mcinnes and mr andrew
mcdowell
both candidates showed great commitment
to the european union
and to the function of commissioner
excellent candidates they also both
clearly have significant experience of
eu matters of course from different
perspectives
following these interviews i have
decided to propose to the council
and the european parliament the
appointment of mrs
mcginnis to the post of commissioner
she will be in charge of financial
services
financial stability and capital markets
union
executive vice president valdis
dombrovskis
will assume responsibility for the trade
portfolio
and he will remain the commission's
representative
on the eurogroup alongside with
commissioner gentileoni
mrs mcginnis has significant
political experience on eu
issues having been an mep since 2004
and currently holding the post of first
vice president of the european
parliament
this experience is crucial in carrying
forward
the eu's financial sector policy agenda
and ensuring it supports and strengthens
the commission's key
priority notably the twin green
and digital transition i would like to
express my thanks
to mr mcdowell for his application and
wish him
well in his future endeavors thank you